Take it. Good morning.
I know.
Okay.
Hey, Lee, good morning.
Hello, hello, how's it going?
Pointy.
Doing good. Thank you.
Good, I'm going to let the huddle know that we are on with Red Helm so that nobody.
is yelling about where are we all.
Any news on Aaron, Kris?
Uh...
Not yet, like, I will update you on that on that part.
The.
Go.
This call is getting recorded.
Mhm.
Hello, Tom Vishal. Good morning.
Nice to meet you.
Good morning, Kris. Good morning, Kate. Good morning, Lee.
Hey, good day, Sameer. How are you today?
Good, good.
So, uh, John is here, we will let him in.
Sounds good.
Go for it, Kris.
Hey, John, good morning.
Hey, guys.
John.
Are you doing?
Hey, John, good morning.
Hello, John. Hello, John.
Ditto.
Good morning, all.
Yeah.
Good to see you both. How's the week train everybody?
Brutal.
Oh, that's not that's not the word you want to hear. I'm so sorry.
Yeah, I just got a lot going on with phones.
Ohh.
Hopefully, uh...
How's that internal or like your customer base?
Internal, just call hold times and whatnot. So we actually, as of this morning, implemented a new process for agent prioritization. So we now have people broken out to either be more phone-centric or less phone-centric. So I'm hoping that alleviates some of the problems.
Okay.
But yeah, for weeks now, we've been dealing with like max hold times of like 45 minutes and stuff. And yeah, exactly. So trying to get that under control. Really, probably we've been dealing with that for like 3 months. So.
Off.
I understand. Well, I'm sorry to hear.
Lee, I don't know. Have I met you before?
We've seen on emails and I actually have a follow up with you because Lee Whitaker and I were discussing a couple of roles and I think he handed off some resumes to you. So part of the reason I'm here is say hello to Cassie and John. Part of the reason I'm here is to meet you and say hello and talk follow up on that. But we can.
Yeah.
We can pin that till later on. But yeah, no, pleasure to meet you. I head up our dedicated product. I work out of our New Jersey office. I've met Cassie, Allison, and John. We've been on a couple of calls together, John Boles, in the past. Yeah, good to see you again. But yeah, nice to formally meet you, John.
Yes, sir.
Larger.
Nice to meet you as well.
Kip.
And Allison, Cassie, pleasure as always.
Hey, Allison, hey Cassie, good morning. Seems like we have a full house today.
Okay.
So...
Welcome everyone to this monthly business review for Red Hub. And today we are going to discuss about the data for the month of May, all right, starting from 1st of May till 31st. I'll quickly share my screen.
We can continue though. We don't have to wait for Cassie.
Sounds good.
Oh.
Okay, allow me one second here.
Akshay.
You're mute thinking nobody will notice you're sneezing. Other than you remember you're on camera. Thank you.
Mmh.
Please let me know if my screen is visible.
It's visible, but...
Yes.
Yeah, that's great, Kris. Thank you.
All right.
Alright, so, as I said, this is for the month of May, starting from 1st of May till 31st. Alright, so...
First, the agenda remains the same. Check in, highlights, action tracker, performance analysis, voice of your customer, way forward, and recap.
Moving forward, how things at this moment. So it's an open house. John, Allison, anything you want to add regarding the team? All right, how things are going on and...
Any feedback for the team?
Um...
We did just go live with some new phone routing prioritizations this morning.
I don't know if we plan to speak more to that later today or later in the meeting, but first day go live, so bear with us. Gotta see how it goes. We'll adjust as needed.
Yeah.
Yep.
Yep, this is something that I think John, John Larger, I mean, me and Kris, we went to call I think last week and John showed us how things would work. So if that's what we're talking about, so yeah, we have slight idea about it, yes.
OK.
Awesome.
All right.
Noel.
Anything else on the engineer, the performance front? Any issues you've noticed recently that you'd like to bring up?
Cassie, John, Allison.
Nothing comes to mind for me right now.
Nothing at the moment.
Okay, so move to the next slide then.
Right.
So these are some highlights from our previous meeting where we have noted the performance, we've done a performance overview, noted overall good performance for the team in terms of utilization, closure, and CSAT metrics. Utilization target for five of the engineers out of seven for the local team, they are able to.
achieve the target. Then we have three of the engineers, out of four, have achieved the target for utilization for enterprise team. Going further, we have closure, all right, where we have seen that Kenneth has the maximum number of closure percentage of 99%, followed by Morris and Irwin.
Then CSAT qualities, we got around 72 surveys. Most of them are excellent. We have analyzed on some of the DSAT remarks, okay? Seems like most of them got revoked. I'm not sure why it's skipping.
Kason.
Next, target focus area, identifying the need to focus on utilization improvement for Grace, Kenneth, and Davis. We'll look into on the numbers right now. Tools access, John Lodge. We already had a word with John regarding this and we're in complete discussion about our requirements and all those things.
And for upcoming holidays for 25th of May, there was a holiday. So we have already, the operation was closed. Okay, so these are the province which we have discussed. Then action track.
Not sure why it's moving. This is the action tracker. There are two action items. One is which has already closed. JB, with your confirmation, we have closed the SIP part. Keith has already confirmed with you. And regarding the access, okay.
who we are already in discussion with John Larger and the team.
Okay.
All right, so these are ITBD recommended KPIs.
One small thing, Kris, sorry, I was talking on mute. Sorry to put you on spot, John. Any update on the, I mean, anything on the access piece? Not an update, but anything, anything for us?
Unfortunately, no.
Okay, no worries.
Right, these are activity recommended KPIs where billable utilization target is at 80%, ticket resolution ticket resolution per day remains at 8 to 10, customer CSAT and 95%, response rate at 30%, SLA compliance 95%, FTR first.
Touch resolution remains at 60%, same day resolution rate 80%. So John, these are the metrics which basically we want to check more if we get the proper access for the engineer, right, so that we can find out those numbers to improve the service, add more value.
And how are you guys getting those numbers today?
Right.
Okay, so right now, these are the ITBD recommended KPIs, all right? So most of them, we are not able to find it. For example, SLA, FTR, and same day resolution, we are not able to find yet. Okay, but this is our recommendation for a better service.
OK.
Got it, okay.
Yeah, yeah, so this is a list of ideals. And this is one of the reasons we're asking for that access or visibility. It doesn't have to be direct access, could always be a report you guys are comfortable sending, configuring on a weekly basis or whatever. That would give us a lot of great insight into being able to help track these on our side.
Right.
Yeah, and I know one thing that we discussed that I'll need to discuss with the SDMs and then take that to.
probably our innovation team is, I know one of you at one point had access to Power BI in the old environment and getting that access in the new environment and what that looks like.
Yep.
Sure.
Kris did, yeah.
Yeah, it was me.
So moving to the next slide, this is the performance analysis for the HD local team. The team performance overall utilization for the team remains at 78%, which has dropped from 80 if we compare it with the month of April. In the month of April, it was 80.57.
OK, however, 4 out of seven engineers has achieved the target of 80% below billable utilization, where Ishan has topped the chart. He's at 87.51 percentage, and then we have Razdan, he's at 86, then Neo, he's at 83, then Kaila, she's at 82.
Okay, so if we talk about Grace, if we compare the two numbers for the month of April and May, Grace has improved a little bit, all right. However, still there is scope of improvement. She's at 75.2, though she's very close. But yes, she's not able to achieve the 80% billable utilization.
However, at this time, Joe is also not able to meet the target of 80% billable. Okay, we are working with them to find out what exactly created these issues. Okay, however, if I talk about...
Kenneth, he is in off of a shift. OK, his available utilization remains at 47%, which has significantly dropped from 67%. However, over here, the main reason behind this is that earlier, Kenneth used to get all the escalated tickets from them.
in-house knock team. Now those ticket goes to the Columbia team, so he's not working on those tickets. And the second concern was he was getting some fishing tickets. Right now those tickets also got dried up. So he's getting very less number of tickets. That is the only reason he is available utilization is.
Oh.
Getting dropped.
So I'm not concerned about that billable utilization number, but I do want to figure out how we're better able to leverage him during that time. And I think that's probably on us, not on him, not on you. But I think that we can probably make better use of him.
Mmh.
Um...
Definitely, definitely.
But the understanding the why, I think we all are aligned there.
Yeah, for Kenneth, I do understand that Kenneth is the kind of person, he's very resourceful, all right, very knowledgeable and very keen to work on different kind of issues. So definitely we can use his expertise on a different kind of technologies, all right, by providing him more work on
any kind of issues. Moving further,
All right, so this is the billable utilization for the enterprise team. The average billable utilization for the team is at 80%. If I compare this with the month of April, it has dropped from 83 to 80. All right, there's 3% of drop on billable utilization.
Out of four, three engineers are able to achieve the 80% believable utilization, but yes, if I talk about the top performer, Shiva is at 86.49%, Maurice following by 86.49, then Arvind, he is at 89, right? Then...
Ohh.
Sorry, he's at 85.39% and then we have Davis, he's at 64%. So we have seen a significant close to 8 to 9% of drop if I talk about our previous month. But yes, on our previous month also, he was not able to achieve the numbers. So John, over here, I just want to add something like.
Recently, I've seen like there are some changes in terms of queue, like some tickets during the first half of the shift, people are aligned for calls and then the next of next half of the shift they are aligned for the ticket picking up, they are supposed to pick up the tickets from the board, so like this is actually affecting.
Davis, because he has very low number of tickets to work on because he don't have the full access for the full stream. Okay, and he was not getting, I'm sorry, yes, Allison.
No, Davis has had access to full steam now for over a month.
Kam.
Yeah, he do have access to Folsom, but there are a few tickets which he is not working. For example, like Morris and Shiva, they are working on Jira tickets as well. So that actually...
Let's move now to Service Now, but yes, we have plenty of full steam tickets he can be working in Halo. There are not a lack of full steam tickets.
Okay, okay.
No, and our SLA in Halo for full steam specifically is not good. So, like, I want to say it's like 70% right now, attainment. Now, I don't know how much that overlaps with Davis's shift, but I think.
Okay.
So for Davis, pardon me, Davis, Joe, and Grace, there will be no lack of work and prioritization of that work. So we did away with the whole, you know, first hour, first, you know, morning versus afternoon and all of that. And it's just straight. This is how prioritized you are within.
all of the queues that you're in all of the time. And those three individuals all are our frontline phone centric people. So they should just be able to basically move phone call to phone call.
Okay.
Seriously doubt there will actually be any downtime in between calls.
Okay, all right, John. Thanks for the insight. Definitely, I will, yeah, Cassie, want to add something.
Well, sorry, I don't know if I heard that correctly. I just wanted to, John, did I hear you say Joe was also working those tickets because Joe doesn't work full state, but perhaps I didn't understand. Okay, then I think I didn't hear it.
No, we had touched on a, yeah, for Joe and Grace, we had touched just in general on their utilization and whatnot. And they are all phone-centric people, regardless of which queues they're in or not in. So.
Kip.
OKOK.
Definitely, we can. I can work with the team, all right, to improve the numbers, right? For Davis, right? This was one of the concerns because last month I have seen for a couple of months, a couple of weeks, he was only aligned to the full stream queue only. So other tickets are not coming, only full stream phone tickets, okay? The tickets which get generated from phone calls, okay?
So those tickets actually hampered him, but yes, if I compare this with the month of April, still in the month of April also, he was not able to achieve the number. So I'm working with him to see, all right, how we can improve his number. All right.
Moving further, anything else, Keith, you want to add on this?
I'm good, buddy. Thank you.
Right.
Okay, so moving further, this is the ticket closure for the local team. Okay, so the average ticket closure numbers has improved from 87.86% for the month of April to 90.71% for the month of May. All right, where all the...
Most of the engineers are able to achieve some good numbers, right? As you can see, the top performers are Kenneth, he is at 98%, right? Once again, once again, Neo and Joe, they are also at 98%, followed by Grace, she is at 97%.
Ishan, he's at 90% and Kaila is at 81% and then Razdan is at 73%. Okay, so for Razdan, I'm working with him, okay, to see what exactly things are lacking. Okay, we can see the slight improvement on that. We have discussed about it.
during our last service call. Seems like I'm trying to find out if there are any kind of issues or challenges in terms of technical knowledge or something like that, which is hampering the things. But yeah, we are working on this. Anything you want to add, Allison or Cassie?
No.
Noel.
Right. Okay, so overall our team has worked on 1,132 tickets out of which they are able to close 1,022 tickets as a team.
I will.
If I move to...
So there's, if I notice Kenneth's performance, I mean, he has closed, like I think he stopped the chart almost on second after Razdan, but his utilization is low. So the time entry is probably on the tickets. I'm not sure if that's the problem for him because.
Yes, yes.
Yes.
Yeah, actually, Kenneth, Keith, as I said, Kenneth is working mostly. He was getting fishing alert tickets, all right? So the time entries are very low on those tickets, right? It doesn't take much time to fix those tickets. Yes, the ticket numbers are high, but utilization numbers are low on that.
Mm.
Hmm, okay, okay, right.
Yeah.
Kam.
S.
On the off-hour shift, as we have discussed, so that is really intriguing him.
Mhm.
Kam.
So this is ticket closure for the month of May for Enterprise Team. Maurice stopped the chart with 100% closure. He has worked on 290 ticket out of which he is able to close 290. Then we have Shiva, he stopped the chart. He has worked on 293 and...
able to close to 183. He is at a closure percentage of 97 percent. Then we have Davis, he has worked on 113 tickets out of which he was able to close 80 tickets. Then we have Arvind, he has worked on 136 tickets out of which he was able to close 134. Overall team looks good.
But yes, once again, David, I'm working with him to see, as you have mentioned, John, that you should not have any issues with the full stream tickets, okay? He has proper access for everything, okay? And as of today, I have already checked, he got the access for all the queues, okay? So I hope...
For the last one, I have, last week I have checked his number has improved. So I'm hoping definitely he will show some good numbers on this.
All right, so this is the CSAT.
Where?
All right, so most of the engineers are able to achieve the 100% CSAT. OK, only Razdan. He got one poor survey for the ticket, which is related to...
A two-factor authentication seems like he has resolved the ticket on the timely manner and everything he has confirmed the resolution. OK, everything was fine, but...
Customer has reported that it was not confirmed with him that issue was resolved. Closing the ticket without confirmation. This is what has been mentioned. So though I can see on the ticket itself, it is mentioned that he has already confirmed the resolution and customer confirmed. Yes, it is working fine, but.
Yes, I have informed or updated Razdan on those kind of issues. All right, he should get a confirmation on the last email that yes, it is resolved.
Alright, anything you want to add, Cassie?
But anything, anything on you guys, Allison and Cassie, did you get a chance to listen to this call by any chance?
Which month was that in? Because I'm not seeing, for the past two months, I'm not seeing a negative CSAT. You said that was for Razdan?
Yeah.
Yes.
Oh, I'm only looking at my people, that's why. Sorry, never mind.
I can share the ticket number here if you want.
Okay.
Yeah, if, if you would, please.
Oh sure, yeah, if you have it handy.
Yeah.
Uh...
Management.
Because I know I did just get one yesterday for somebody that in my review, there was nothing done wrong. I think it was a misclick on the user side. I'm just waiting for confirmation. I'm wondering if that's the same ticket.
Mm.
And usually I provide that to Kris, but perhaps I missed one, 559. Thank you.
But this one is surprising for me because it's Razdan we are talking about. So, yeah.
Yeah.
Okay.
So, altogether, we have received forty-six surveys. OK, out of which forty-one are excellent, and four of them are good, and one for for Razdan.
Best all the engineers have received the 100% CX.
So, Allison, I do see you reviewed that one.
Yeah.
Okay.
This particular end user is...
difficult to work with, I'll say.
Mhm.
He oftentimes doesn't respond to us when we reach out. He doesn't respond more than he does respond. So I'll review again, but I'm confident Razdan did what was needed on this. Just knowing our regular experience with this end user.
Mm-hmm.
Mhm.
Oh.
Thank you. Thank you, Allison. Yeah.
Right, so, so we'll be in touch since, if you remember, we mentioned the last time as well that we maintain an internal scorecard for these guys, so yeah, for now, for now I'll be marking him down for this particular CSAT, but whenever you confirm, I'll be able to, you know, strike that off.
Sure.
Mhm.
Yeah.
Sure, thank you.
Awesome. Thank you.
Right. Thank you.
All right, these are way forward, as we have discussed in our last meeting: weekly performance assessment, regular ticket, which I am doing on a daily basis, enhance QA process, pre-escalation review for the tickets to reduce unnecessary escalation before escalating any ticket. All right, they should consult with me. All right.
Yeah.
Most of them, as I can see, with the numbers only, escalation numbers are very low, but still, we keep a close eye on them. Control lead planning, okay, two weeks early notice for any planned PTOs. Recognition of the team achievements within the team, we provide the recognition for...
Last quarter, Razdan has received RNR from Razdan team internally.
And internal level up training sessions, which is happening for all the engineers as for their skill set and as for their...
Attenure with the organization, we provide them the training and they can appear for the next level.
Anything else you want to add, Allison, John, Cassie, for the best practices?
Way forward.
Yeah, I have a couple of things. So to circle back to the previous slide or a couple of previous, as far as the customer stack goes, just also keep in, I'm not saying that data is invalid, but keep in mind that it is less useful because of our response rate.
Yeah, please.
So our response rate is something like 3%. That's not a statistically significant number. So for Razdan, like, you know, that one bad one, you know, it brought him below the threshold. Like, I mean, you know, I think it would be a different picture if we, you know, had a 10% response rate or something like that. So.
Mm.
Ohh.
Just something to keep in mind. We are going to make a push on CSAT response rate at some juncture. I'm guessing we're probably at least a month away from that. But we're going to be trying to push customers to the portal more and just a number of customer experience type initiatives.
In the mine.
So hopefully we'll get more data from that. I do want to talk about the controlled leave planning. So I'm open to how we do it. And this is a question as much for the SDMs as anything.
But we need a way to track this effectively.
Bing.
You know, what do you, SDMs, what do you feel is the right answer right now? Just doing it in shifts based on emails from them or?
or how we log in on ourselves.
Mhm.
Yeah, I'd rather not.
The word I'm looking for has just left my brain. I'd rather not break out from what we're already doing for the rest of the team. So if we're not moving everyone's shifts somewhere else, then I'd rather not move only ITBD shifts somewhere else personally. I'll do whatever y'all ask me to do. But if we can keep them together, I'd like to do that.
Now another thought that I had that I don't even know if it's technically possible, one of our HR people said that it probably is, would be to basically set up a dummy paid time off plan within ADP and they request it there. So it would be following the same channels as everything else and be able to
Don't want to deviate, yeah.
Keith.
report on it. I'm assuming ITBD would be fine with that if we wanted them to, you know, request it in a certain way. Cassie, you have your hand up.
Absolutely.
Yeah, so sorry, my team's shut down again and I was moving to my phone. I missed the initial question.
So what were you asking?
Controlled leave planning. So if an ITBD person is going to be off, how we are aware of that and track that.
So we don't have that situation like we had around Memorial Day where, you know, we had multiple ITBD people off and limited resources for full steam right after their ticket cut over.
That client specifically wants notified whenever one of them is going to be on PTO, which I haven't agreed to that yet, and I don't know that I will, but it's not an unreasonable ask either.
Well...
Perhaps I don't know the history here, but I mean, they do let us know for time off. Of course, sick time, we just, we get that notice day of. And we've asked for two weeks, which I think they've been pretty good about. So perhaps I'm not clear on what happened around Memorial Day.
Just.
But if you're asking for a change.
Sorry.
Okay.
full steam stuff.
Understood.
Okay, so I have a suggestion, like for full stream, we have Morris and Shrivastava. Okay, so regarding them, maybe like we can raise on a particular email desktop somewhere, like everyone should be aware that this particular full stream engineer will be off on that particular day, or maybe some kind of calendar or something like that.
Mmh.
just to check on those engineer.
Yeah, I don't know that we have a solved today. The ADP piece might help. Otherwise, we'll just keep doing it in shifts, just make sure that they're giving us that advance whenever possible. Obviously, sick days are sick days, you know.
Mhm.
Mm-hmm.
Yeah.
So, um...
And then do we have through the month of the end of June right now of, did we, I think we got a list right, Cassie?
Yeah, I think we were, I think just this morning, JB approved the final two.
Mhm.
Okay.
Oh yes, I believe we do not know.
Kip.
Oh, and I did like having that rollout request. That was nice to see them all in one. So yeah, maybe that was for me, at least that was very helpful to see them all together.
When possible. I understand it won't always be possible.
Yes.
Agreed.
It can be. He maintains a tracker of that sort on his end. So yeah, if you feel that's a better way to share leaves, cascade leaves, I mean, of course, he connects with the individuals while preparing their roster for the upcoming month. He checks with them if they have any planned leaves and he adds them to his database. So yeah, he can follow the same format if he has.
any bulk requests for sure. But a couple of questions from you too, John, since you mentioned about CSAT first. One quick question. Sorry if it's a silly question, but the CSATs are being triggered and all the tickets that they're working on, all of them.
Yeah.
I don't have an answer. SDMs, do you guys know that answer?
Kour.
Yeah. The only way one would not be triggered is if the contact on the ticket was general user, which is often only used for something that, say I open a ticket because I need someone to dig into something quickly. The user didn't request that, so I'm going to leave that with no user attached to it. So that wouldn't send out a.
Oh.
Mhm.
Mm.
a CSAT, but that would be the only example I'm aware of.
Okay, that's the only example, right? Because 150 tickets on an average by every individual and then overall 40 surveys. So you're right on that part, John. The response rate is very less. But one suggestion, I'm not trying to pitch for the same access request again, but just giving an example for one of our...
So.
other partners where one of my DTLs has the access to their board. So what he does is when an engineer closes a ticket two or three days after the closure, the DTL connects with the end user to check how things are, just a general check. And then if the survey was not fair, probably pitch on that call that okay, if you like my engineers.
services and if the issue is resolved but requested, please go ahead and fill the form, rather fill the feedback for this individual, something like that. Just see that pitch. So if ever, if you're able to get that sort of access for Kris, maybe he can, or I think he already has the access to the VSA. So if maybe to get the, if he can get the access to the.
phone system, if you think it'll be good for him to connect with the end users and kind of pitch for surveys, we can do that as well to improve the response rate.
Yeah, we can definitely keep that in mind.
I'm gonna let John take that one.
Okay, nice. And the other one, sorry again, giving a few examples, but for a few other partners for leaf planning, we either follow the same process like we do over here over the email, but some of the partners, they have maybe certain forms they want the engineers to fill. Some of them use.
ADB and Bamboo, where they can, you know, go and apply, post your approval over an email, or maybe for now, if we don't have anything in place, we can keep a common tracker where Kris can go and update for you guys, so that's always readily available for you, John, Cassie, Allison.
And we're talking about PTO now again. Yeah, yeah, yeah. I mean, I think a common tracker and or those roll up emails is probably sufficient for this second while we.
PTO, yeah, sorry, I switched my bad, yeah.
explore some other options like ADP potentially.
Sure, sure. Perfect. A shared tracker, or I mean, me and Kris will discuss internally. A shared tracker, or every Monday Kris shares the stats for the team, their utilization and their closure. Along with that, he can also attach the leaves approved so far for this month kind of a tracker, so that everybody's on the same page. So yeah, we can try multiple things here.
OK, that sounds great.
But...
Awesome, I have one request. Sorry, it's a very important one. For, I think I dropped an email for this a couple of weeks ago. It's regarding Kiara and Shiva. As you guys know, I'm not sure if John, you're aware of it, but they're married, right? They're a couple. So.
Whenever.
If there are any planned leaves or there's an emergency leave, mostly this happens where, you know, both of them unfortunately call out together. I mean, they avail their leaves together. They travel together to office, so if there's a traffic issue or some rd blockage, both of them are laid together. Before it...
Could you know create it before it can turn into a big issue? I just wanted to discuss about the same with you guys and see if you know maybe we should look into this from a different lens and see if I know both of them do a really good job on their respective pods, one for enterprise, one for local, but do you think...
we should think of maybe getting a replacement done for either of the engineer. Do you think that sounds like a plan? I'm not saying that it's causing a very big issue, but of course, yeah, we've noticed and you know, I'm pretty sure you guys have noticed the trend as well where their plan leaves, of course, somebody's birthday or a wedding or they're going for an outing or something, they're going together, right? And.
That's of course how it should be, but it's we of course don't want to do that on the at the cost of the operations for sure. So I just wanted to bring that up and see what you guys have. You want to understand your take on this.
I think that's part of.
Personally, I don't think it has caused problems. Sorry, go ahead, Cassie.
I would agree with what Allison just said, and I would say that I think that's one of the reasons we've got them on different teams, let's call it, enterprise versus local, so they don't directly overlap each other's absence. I wouldn't ever say that any other two engineers could not take the same time off together, so those two don't bother me that they're off together.
Mhm.
Okay.
Mm.
So to me, it's not a huge problem, but I'll let my peers lay in.
Mhm.
Okay. Okay.
I mean, I could see, you know, and this is going to be so few and far between, but I could see maybe if they're requesting a day where we already have people with planned PTO, that might limit us in our ability to approve their PTO together potentially, but I don't think we've run into that thus far and they've been now with us for over a year.
Closer to two years, I think.
Mhm.
Yeah, I think they were married about a year ago.
Yeah.
Yeah, they were. They were. Okay. Well, good to hear that. Thank you for that. And I mean, I just wanted to bring it out here just to understand your view on this. And it's really, really happy to hear that because I really like both the individuals. They're great team members and I didn't want to lose any of them.
Mhm.
But yeah, in case I wanted to put it out there, in case you have, maybe you notice any sorts of issues with their performance because of the same issue that I've just raised, just please feel free and let me know. All right, we can definitely, sure.
What I might ask.
Sure.
What I might ask there is, is it a given if one is sick, does that preclude the other from coming to work? I mean, is it a driving or transportation issue that they need to come in together? Because I get, you're right, if one is sick, they seem to both be out. And I understand in a household how that means two people could be sick. But I would like to not assume that if one was sick, the other can't work.
Mm.
Um, I don't know if that's understood.
No, not, no, that doesn't work. I mean, that, it's not the case when one of them or either of them are sick. Yes, it happened once when I think Shiva or I think Shiva, Shiva's mother was hospitalized and both of them had to take that emergency leave when they were in the hospital with their mother. But I don't think when, it never happens when either of them are sick. Correct me if I'm wrong, Kris.
Support.
Yeah, you're right. Regarding sick leaves, like it's okay, like if one of them are on sick leave, the other is working. But yeah, due to family emergencies, both of them need to be there. So as a family, I understand that part, but it hampers our business or the process. That's what's the only concern.
Right.
Right, I understand that.
Yeah, same page.
Mhm.
Thank you.
Yeah.
Right, that was...
Yeah, I think it's good to raise the awareness and point it out, but...
Pre.
I don't have an issue with it if it's not causing a problem for us and it doesn't sound like it is so.
Yeah.
That's really supportive of you guys. Thank you so much for that. Right, lovely. Over to you, Kris.
Thank you.
And one more thing, the 19th, I saw a message from Cassie, I guess, in case, so you, in case you require any sorts of coverage on that day, just to let us know.
Okay.
Alright, for now, that's the that's the case, right? Sorry.
But speaking of holidays.
We have one more on 3rd, I guess.
Before our next service call, so, like...
Do we need any coverage from ITBD end, or like how exactly all the regular operation remain closed on 3rd of July?
Well.
I'm sorry.
I don't think, and so my peers speak up, please, or John larger. I don't think we're going to look for coverage on the 19th of June or the 3rd of July.
We just traditionally have not needed extra coverage. We consider that a holiday and we're shut down that day.
Okay, right.
We have on-call engineers taking any emergencies as well.
Hello.
Mhm.
Good call out.
Show.
So, are we saying...
I do know that.
as well as our knock now working tickets.
Are we saying, Cassie, that ITBD will also, on our side, will also be shut down because it's a holiday?
Correct. That is traditionally correct. That is traditionally how that we've operated. Although if we want to make a change there, it sounds like they're open to it.
Okay.
Yeah, yeah, like...
Yeah, and Preston had Preston had started the conversation at one point in the past of potentially keeping because they have their own holidays, they work as well, or excuse me, that they have off as well. So there was a conversation that started, but we never really landed anywhere. So we can certainly revisit.
Yeah.
Mhm.
Though there are overlap there.
So, I mean, I'm looking at the, for the India holidays for 2026, you know, May 25th and Wild Days was listed there, July 3rd is listed there. So,
Mhm.
Yeah, July 3rd I'm less concerned about. The 19th I am because...
Um...
I don't even know the percentages of companies that
observe that, but it's definitely not all. I think I would like the ITBD people working on the 19th.
Okay.
I don't want our on-call to get overloaded.
Right.
Okay, so we can definitely do that. And yeah, so I can also share the calendar that we have, the Indian and US calendar that the team follows with you, John. And yeah, for Indian holidays as well, not the entire team, not the whole team. They don't take off together, but yeah, they apply and based on the availability we provide them offs.
For US holidays, in this case, like Allison mentioned, yes, so Preston did start this piece, wherein I think it was it happened for the first time on the Labor Day, or sorry, what US holiday it was, but Joe, I think, requested, yeah, and and I think...
It might have been Labor Day. Yeah, that sounds right. It's been a while.
Hi.
Yeah, so that that when...
I think it was Thanksgiving last year.
All right, yes, it was Thanksgiving, November, correct. So that's when Joe requested for the team to be available. I think it was two days prior to the event and the team was very supportive and they did show up. And then that's when we and Joe, we came to this agreement that yes, the team, if they want, if the team needs to work on US holidays, if we could get.
Oh, yes.
Thanksgiving, it was.
to get the request like a week prior so that we can make sure the arrangements are there because team kind of, you know, plan their leaves accordingly. So here we have good ample amount of time for the 19th and I'll make sure. You want the entire team to be operational, John, or should we kind of create a plan for you guys and share and let you know?
Mhm.
I think with our current state.
I probably prefer they all be operational or close. Like if there's some people that are already off, you know, like if you get any pushback, that's fine. But I think that would be a good opportunity for us to actually make some headway on, you know, some queues and whatnot.
Okay.
Mhm.
Mm.
Cool, cool. We've broken that beat.
And does that include Kenneth?
I'm just that I'm just curious.
Ohh.
When?
He's the 6pm to 3am shift.
So...
Yeah, but he not on Fridays, right?
Yeah, Fridays as well, Monday through Friday. So he works till 3am Saturday.
Okay.
Eastern.
It's BSI patching. Sorry, it's I'm sorry. We're talking about the next Friday. Never mind, never mind, never mind.
Um...
Ah, yeah, the 19th.
Yeah, sorry, I was I was thinking about this week. I need him this week.
Ah.
Yeah, I kind of, I don't really feel strongly one way or another. If he's available and can work, great. If he has an obligation, that's fine too.
Kour.
John, I'll tell you right now that I was asked and already approved for Joe Friday. It's the Independence Day in the Philippines, and I'd already approved that. So FYI, I guess I could rescind it right now if you're uncomfortable with that idea. The 12th, this Friday.
Right.
For the 19th.
Other 12.
As it happens, she's been out today than yesterday.
I mean, I have no issues with that.
with allowing her the day.
As long as you know we don't have a ton of people out or anything, that's fine.
We didn't anti-hi jacked. All right, thanks.
Yeah.
So should I go ahead and update shifts now? And then Keith or Kris, if you do have anyone that has plans and is not able to make it that day, let us know. Or John, do you want me to wait to update shifts until we know for sure who will be able to work?
I think we should tell them first. I don't know who's going to do that, you folks or us. I can talk to the four that report to me.
I would say.
Yeah.
No, we we connect with individuals, uh, may probably after this call, and we we'll collate a list and share with you guys for sure.
Thank you.
And then Allison, I would say, go ahead and update shifts and they'll let us know if anyone can't do it.
That's what I was going to say as well, but I don't feel strongly in.
in the order of operations there.
Okay.
Anything else? So if I understand correctly, on 19th, we have all the engineers logged in. In case anyone has a planned leave or something like that, they can go for the PTO. Rest of the engineers will be logged in as for the shift.
Okay, and I do just want to call out it looks like Arvin already has.
Yeah.
That week off, although JB, if the market is out of office and not PTO, is that?
It's he just that's one of the ones that was just requested. Aren't we?
Do you know what that is?
I don't know, I just put out of office because it was requested and he asked for it. I don't know if it should be PTO or out of office, but...
Yeah, generally out of office is reserved for when someone calls out, but I don't, I don't know, maybe I missed a conversation where we're logging ITBD differently.
No.
So the plane.
I think in that SOP that we have around shifts, I was hoping to see some of that get in there, you know, how we use the colors and how we, you know, actually put in the times and whether we use OO or PTO or out or sick or, you know, whatever it may be.
Mm.
Okay.
Because that should be consistent across all all SDMs and all staff.
ITBD or otherwise.
I got to look at that SOP. I think that SOP was waiting for you guys to take a look at it, if I recall correctly. But the reason I brought it up is I believe Arvind's already out that week, and so he likely already has plans on that day, so we should probably keep him off for that.
rather than take back one of the days we already.
I would agree.
Kip.
Let me, let me check, and I can maybe share the list to whoever is available, right? I'm pretty sure, like most of the engineers will be available. Let's see.
Done.
Okay.
Oh.
Right, I think we have a good amount of action items with us. Chris, of course, you'll jot them down and share in the minutes. But do you have any other slides apart from this?
Yeah.
No, I think I'm end of the slide. This AI by design, which we have already discussed, and this recap.
Team GPS, our concern team is already working with the Razdan team regarding this, and that's it on the slides part. I'm done.
Right, anything, sorry if that's already been covered. Lee, anything on the build it piece in your discussion with the or anybody, are they coming to build it?
Yeah, yeah, I mean, we've got Michael coming as a speaker, and I think there are other team members that are...
Seems like...
Lee and Jason about a yes, true day. Sorry, my computer stood up quickly. But yeah, no, overall, I think we're going to build it. The only other thing that I had on my list for today was checking in with the group about the open positions that.
Okay.
Lee Whitaker requested of us. So we shared some resumes that I think have made their way to people in this group, but I'm not sure.
Guess.
Me and Allison, yeah.
I think I, I think it's waiting on me, actually. I forgot about that.
Okay.
Oh, okay.
Yeah, we crossed some wires there, so I think I was actually asking to have to set up some interviews and then I think one of the individuals was no longer available. I would have preferred that we just schedule with the other individual at that point, but it's no big deal. I just missed the reply and...
and didn't circle back to it. You guys wouldn't believe what my inbox looks like. Yes, I think interviewing 2 individuals makes sense. Allison, I would like you to chime in if you want it to be those two or if we want to.
Do another role.
And look at some others.
OK.
Yeah, and I don't know.
I don't know who owns or runs the budgeting component, but just so that you know, when Lee came to me, he said, we might need two to three people. Let's start with two open positions. So I don't know what that means for you all, but if I'm ever handed an opportunity to add to my team, I'm always saying, oh, okay.
Let me interview three or four people in hopes of closing for the two. So I just wanted to make sure you guys had awareness that that's how the conversation went there. So if you want...
Yeah.
When was that conversation?
This was approximately 3 weeks ago. And then we got the resumes over, I think, within a week. We had a couple in front of you guys. And so it's been a week and a half or so of back and forth.
Okay.
Yeah.
So...
We're trying to do...
more in-house for the backfills that we can simply because, like, I agree with Lee, like it makes sense to have, you know, multiple work pools, right, for some steadiness and some capacity planning and all of that. But right now, we're not able to add true headcount.
It's purely backfills and we currently don't have ITBD people participating in our after hours on-call rotations. So that's why I would prefer to fill more of them with direct roles if we can, especially if they're coming from, you know,
Mm.
Right.
If the direct roll left.
I kind of want to fill that with a direct role so that way I want to get everybody to be basically be on call one week out of every eight. That's my target.
And then.
I...
and trying to accommodate that. But that doesn't mean that we shouldn't at least, you know, I think we're going to have at least one coming from your side, possibly more.
Do you know offhand, are you able to share like what does a role cost us with your organization?
Well...
So, it does depend on skill set, but...
Mhm.
But we are in, I would say, anywhere from...
When we're looking here, I see the range of about 2,500 at the lower end to about 4,300 at the higher end, monthly.
Okay, and then this is...
And actually, we should, we should, let me actually modify that slightly. I think your highest, your highest paid engineer is probably closer to 35 or so.
Okay.
And...
What is the, and this is more nitty-gritty and not necessarily what we hear typically we deal with, but I want to know some options. What is the minimum contract length?
So we usually like a year, however, we already in as part of the partnership, you guys are a strategic partner. You've got a decent headcount. We're working with you guys to help, you know, both of us grow.
Okay.
So I think Lee was looking at six months when he brought these up to us. And we were saying, yeah, that's fine. And usually when we do anything under a year, there's a modification to the rate, but we're going to keep them in line with where your rates are now.
as like a sign of good faith, right? Like just basically keeping, not wanting to mess with that while you guys are going through your, the internal transitions you guys are going through.
Yeah. Do you have anything, and obviously it would come at a premium, super short term, like 6 weeks?
Is that something that is even an option?
We have, but we have, what, what would be the objective of the work? Would it be like...
If someone if someone's on leave trying to provide backfill for them, and I know that it would take a little bit of time to train them up, but I feel like maybe you know we could be strategic in in what they work on and in trying to.
If.
Alright.
you know, cover some key areas and then let the team fill in the rest.
Yeah, let me take that back. It's not something we've never done, right? But to your point, it's not a standard because, you know, most people are looking at their environments and saying, well, this is complex and a six week just gets them dabbling in the water and doesn't
May or may not prove valuable, so if you believe that there's value.
provided for their capability of value being provided from that. I'm not against the conversation. We just want to take a look at how we make sure, because what we don't want to do is we don't want to put somebody in there that's going to not meet your needs. Yeah, exactly, exactly.
Not help. Yeah.
Exactly, like if your need doesn't get met, it's better off for us to just agree that that doesn't make sense for us to put ourselves in a position to both not help you make me put a sour note on what the service is doing, right? So we'd want to be considerate about it, but I'm open to the discussion.
Yeah.
Rick.
Kip.
I wanted to ask quickly, are Dexter and Raul still the two candidates that we're going to schedule for interviews, or has that changed?
You.
Yep, descent role, yes.
Okay. Do they have preferences for the date of the interview or are they just open to whenever?
Yeah, whenever, I mean, based on your convenience, of course.
Okay.
Um...
This Thursday, I'm pretty open.
If that's is that too soon, if I were to find a time that works for us.
This Thursday.
What slot for this Thursday, if I can maybe connect with the team and ask them to connect with these two folks and see if they can be available around that time. So what time suits you?
That would be the 11th.
Kip.
Sure, yeah.
Yeah, let me know. Well, let me know their availability that day. Most of the meetings I have that day, I can move around.
Mm.
If needed.
Mhm.
So yeah, let's see if they are both available that day within the same time frame so that we can just do back-to-back interviews and then we'll see if any of those times that are available work for us. John, are you going to be interviewing with me or will that be Cassie or Dubey?
Okay.
I would say your preference, I would at least like to be included as optional, but I don't want any of the scheduling to depend on me because pretty slammed the next couple of days and then I'm out for a week and a half, so.
Pre.
Okay.
Oh, right. Okay. Yeah, you need that prep day.
Yeah.
Right, so back to back works for you. Perfect. And is there a preference on the duration of the interview? 30 minutes works fine for you guys, or you want an hour at least with each individual?
I think when we tried 30 minutes, we ended up going over, if I'm remembering correctly. Javid, does that sound right? I think you were with me in a few.
Mhm.
Yeah, I think the hour is the best.
Yeah, I'd say at minimum 45 minutes, but an hour is probably safer.
All right, we'll do it that way then. An hour for both. Individuals, of course. All right, that sounds like a plan. I'll connect with the team, like I said, for this coming Thursday, and we'll share the slots with you and get your blessings on that, Allison.
OK.
Awesome. Thank you guys.
Alrighty, anything else from you guys before we wrap it off?
Good. Lovely. All right, Lee, anything from you before we close?
Yeah, I apologize, team. Somebody attacked me from the door, which never happens when I work remote. Anyway, no, that was it. I just wanted to make sure that we had the right information and the right conversation going around that. Kris and Keith, thank you for pulling together everything. And
Red Helpdesk team, great to see you all, as usual, and John, pleasure to meet you. By the way, I will add one more quick thing, as you guys are going through your exercise around bumping up CSAT response rates. This is something that I've been involved in numerous times, both here at IT by Design and...
Before I was here, I was in an MSP for 12 years where we fought the good fight on that and won. So if you guys, if there's any value to having a conversation around it, John, just let me know. More than happy to carve out time and kind of share what I've seen and or offer any thoughts or
or feedback on what you guys are tackling, if I can be of service.
Yeah.
I really appreciate that. Yeah, I think...
Our emails that go out around it are just not good. So I think just even starting there will move the needle quite a bit.
OK.
Great. Okay. Well, that was all for me, Keith.
Perfect. All right. Over to you, Kris. Please close it off.
All right, so.
That's it. Thank you everyone for joining the meeting. I'm going to send you the MM for the meeting. If you have any issues, any concerns, please let us know. And regarding our PTO request, right, all the requests has already been approved. Allison, I have a slight change on the Kenneth request.
I will connect with you on that.
Sure, thank you.
All right, all right. Thank you, everyone. Thanks for joining the call. Bye.
Thank you. Thanks for joining. Bye.
Thanks, all.
You?
Have a great day.
Two.